من الصعب على معظم الناس أن يتخيلوا
مدى الكثافة السكانية في غزة،
أعني أننا سمعنا للتو عن ذلك، لقد
سمعنا عن مقارنات تم
رسمها، أخبرني عن تأثير ذلك
على المرحلة التالية من التوغل البري المحتمل،
نعم هذا  منطقة مثيرة جدًا للاهتمام
أيضًا لورا لأن أه
الجزء الأكثر كثافة سكانية في غزة هو
مدينة غزة نفسها، لذلك هذا الجزء
هنا الذي يضم أكثر من
25000 أه شخص لكل ميل مربع، والبعض الآخر
مثل شمال غزة دير بالا ك يونس
وهي منطقة رئيسية  مخيم اللاجئين ورافع
لديهما كثافة سكانية أقل ولكن لا يزال
كل شيء في غزة هو في الأساس مع
استثناء بسيط 10,000 شخص
أو أكثر لكل ميل مربع، لذلك تفكر في
الكثير من الناس أه محشورين في
منطقة صغيرة جدًا وبالمقارنة فقط
أه هناك أماكن ذات
كثافة سكانية أعلى لكل ميل مربع
حول العالم ولكن غزة لديها
كثافة سكانية أكبر لكل ميل مربع حوالي
21000 شخص لكل ميل مربع في
المناطق الحضرية مقارنة بتل أبيب ولوس
أنجلوس أو هنا في منطقة واشنطن العاصمة
واو عندما  انظر إلى هذه
المقارنة، فهي توضح حقًا
مدى الكثافة السكانية
وأيضًا ما يمكن أن يحدث إذا كانت لديك
قوات تتحرك إلى تلك المناطق، فنحن
نتحدث عن المدنيين في تلك
المناطق على وجه الخصوص، وبالتالي قامت الولايات المتحدة
بنقل الأصول إلى تلك المناطق  في المنطقة، ما هو الدور الذي
يمكن أن تلعبه القوة النارية، إن وجدت،
للمضي قدمًا بشكل جيد؟ هناك الكثير من الأشياء التي
يجب أن نتعامل معها هنا
وأحدها الشوارع الكثيفة، لذا
انظر إلى مدى ضيق الأمور، هذا
ما كنا سنفعله أنا والجنرال كلابر  اتصل
بتقييم أضرار المعركة، أه
فيديو مثالي لأنك ترى الضرر الذي
حدث هنا ولكن انظر إلى مدى غائرة
كل هذا وانظر إلى جميع
المباني المختلفة وانظر إلى مدى صعوبة
المناورة بشيء ما عبر
كل شارع من هذه الشوارع  أه
لذا، هناك الكثير من الأشياء التي ستأتي
إلى المنطقة تشمل شحنات
الذخائر كما ترون هنا من
طائرة الشحن الإسرائيلية هذه أه لديك يو إس إس
جيرالد آر فورد أه بطائراتها من 70 إلى
90 طائرة اعتمادًا على كيفية قيامهم
بمعركة الحاملة  المجموعة وقد جعلتهم
يأتون إلى شرق
البحر الأبيض المتوسط ​​جنبًا إلى جنب مع طائرات f35
وf-15 التابعة للقوات الجوية بالإضافة إلى طائرات a10، كل هؤلاء
يلعبون دورًا كبيرًا في وضع
الوجود الأمريكي في هذه المنطقة والتأكد من أه
أن هذا الصراع لن يحدث.  لن تذهب إلى
أبعد مما هو
مؤكد بالفعل